[Musique]
je m'engagerai bonjour quand j'en ai
envie royals et nous avoir écrit jeumont
godet ou sublime on est au phare enfants
et familles est une organisation de
soins palliatifs pédiatriques dont on
pourra enfin les enfants qui sont
atteints d'une maladie fatale
on aide les familles on les accompagne
tout au long de leur trajectoire de vie
des vies qui sont relativement courtes
et on leur donne du répit des soins de
fin de vie de l'accompagnement on les
aide à passer au travers
deux moments difficiles j'appelais
toujours on est plaint toujours douze
lits et c'est un lieu de vie
ici on célèbre la vie on sait qu'elle
est courte et vous voyez on est des
petits camps des sourires ça fait le
salaire d'une journée
[Musique]
j'avais écrit parce que at même avec
toute cette crise tation vous côtoyez il
ya des histoires extraordinaires d'entre
elles
tout à fait des gens qui se mobilisent
qu'ils s'engagent pour créer des moments
pour des enfants et qui nous supportent
qui sont bienveillants c'est-à-dire
qu'elle elle nous aide activement
c'est pô juste de la compassion de
l'empathie elle nous est une vraie vie
de quartier
exactement
la maison andré gratton ça les bénévoles
sans les gens du quartier sera pas la
même elle serait pas la même et cesser
toute la vie de la maison qui travaille
avec le quartier avec les avec les
bénévoles
la maison elle vit dans son quartier
c'est un quartier qui est en plein
développement et on a des voisins qui
sont extraordinaires
vous en avez assez de qu'est-ce qui vous
a amené à musique cliquez ici écoutez
premièrement moi je te jette un voisin
direct enfants puis c'est drôle ça
commence avec une anecdote que à travers
un projet de rénovation la cour
extérieure
je dois entrer en compte je veux me
rapprocher du fort pour avoir des accès
puis à travers ce rapprochement la bunge
et découvrir la mission de fort j'ai
connu le personnel j'ai connu l
entourage que je me dis wow quel beau
projet quelle belle mission je me dis
mais il faut pour mobiliser des gens
faut s'impliquer il faut faire quelque
chose mais on a monté un projet on a
monté un comité citoyen qui a démarré
comme ça
concrètement pour les tempêtes d'hiver
ont demandé on a juste fait un affichage
sur un alpage à écouter à pied levé les
gens sont venus les gens venaient avec
les enfants pour déblayer les accents le
stationnement on a fait une marche entre
québec et montréal pour amasser des
fonds année dernière on va par la
deuxième édition les phares à des
besoins puis c'est pas seulement des
besoins financiers ont des besoins des
gens qui ont des câlins et environs qui
ont du t1 données puis pour faire
rayonner le stade maison leur ferme ou
psy inspirant merci parce que tout est
dit merci beaucoup
[Musique]
je reste à côté puis je voyais les
enfants on parle j'ai demandé à ceux qui
les accompagnaient s'ils avaient besoin
de gens pour qu'ils m'ont dit oui puis
je me 3ème année on fait vraiment partie
d'une équipe
on peut aussi bien donner à manger à un
enfant on peut aussi bien aidé
l'infirmière a changé une culotte on
peut les aider à marcher à courir on
peut chanter des chansons on peut lire
des histoires puis un peu les uns
bracine quand on regarde on a pas de
virus à l'horizon puis j'ai le plus beau
bénévolat que j'ai pu trouver
oui est-ce que tu les aimes ta maman
ouais ouais
ici vous avez découvert comment commence
à changer votre vie on a découvert qu'on
avait été très petit je pense qu'il y
avait 18 mois en fait c'est l'hôpital
qui nous a parlé une star qui était
probablement glee j'ai vu qu'il y avait
une certaine des crises d'épilepsie
d'argent donc il ya commencé en temps de
crise partout et on arrêtait deux
compères sont les foyers des deux heures
l'après-midi ce qui là est ce que rien
en fait david en une maladie génétique
rare qui s'appelle c'est wild 4 à 1
si sa cause en fait des acv donc d'avis
de faire une série dans mon ventre à la
famille grossesse donc ça les cris des
grosses séquelles à son cerveau surtout
du côté droit
donc c'est de login et les crises
d'épilepsie de soya l'appareil cérébrale
il est temps qu une déficience
intellectuelle donc et comme c'est un
grand garçon trésor il ya comme deux ans
dans sa tête je me disais vous aiderez
de répit quand même oui absolument fait
un peu oui donc car qu'on a commencé à
venir ici je t'aime monoparentales
j'avais pas nécessairement de famille
qui m'aidait donc ce fut salvateur parce
que je pouvais enfin aller chez moi me
coucher pour 48 heures et dormir on a
recommencé à venir ça fait un an
parce qu'en fait on est maintenant
suivie aux soins palliatifs à l'hôpital
parce que justement avec la maladie
génétique rare qu'on ne trouve et on ne
savait pas c'est que juste quelques
années qu'on sait on a compris que les
années sont comptés vous savez que vous
avez un endroit pour venir
si jamais ça se mettaient à accélérer
dans le mauvais sens en fait ici c'est
la seule place où david peut venir en
répit parce qu'il ya besoin de soins
médicaux qui sont donnés par des
infirmières donc a pas d'autres endroits
qui peut aller compte tenu de ces soins
médicaux puis j'essaie aussi justement
que quand qu'on va être rendu à la fin
c'est un choix pour nous on n'ira pas à
l'hôpital c'est ici qu'on va venir c'est
ici qu'on l'envoie vers sa famille
lançant puis j'ai accompagné des amis
qui l'ont vécue dans la dernière année
puis c'est très doux d'être six heures
dans l'amour c'est dans l'accompagnement
dans la bienveillance
on veut que ça qu'on entre si bien sûr
que c'est si triste mais on sent que les
gens sourient absolument absolument je
peux vous dire pour justement est venu
ici dernièrement des amis qui ont perdu
leur enfant puis tout le monde dans les
corridors pleure tout le staff est
touché par ça les gens s'attachent à nos
enfants ils prennent soin d'eux souvent
donc c'est tout le monde que ça touche c
c'est plein d'amour en fait c'est un bel
endroit
oui cette extraordinaire josé la force
quand on est parent a raison qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que la difficulté avec
sophie jeune prince ça me touche que
vous me dit mais qu'est ce que je sens
se faire donc
c'est mon fils je l'aimais je fis ce qui
a fait rire
[Musique]